how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder i'm your host warren
thompson and we just watched the first
two episodes of hawkeye right away let
me know what you thought about the first
two episodes in the comments down below
did you like it did you not like it what
did you hope would be different about it
what were you expecting that maybe
didn't happen or did you just think that
it was perfect now i'm gonna do a shot
by shot breakdown of episode one and two
but i'm also going to talk a lot about
how i think that
kingpin could be behind everything
that's happening yes
eleanor bishop is acting super sus right
now yes she could be madame mask she's
not the comics but perhaps mcu can
retcon her to actually be in madame mask
in this tv show but there are a lot of
things that actually connect to kingpin
in this show including one the auction
now in the comics the auction's in
madrid
but in the comics kingpin is a part of
the auction he's a prominent member of
the auction then we have the tracksuit
mafia who in the comics the matt
fraction run is funded by kingpin and
then we have qazi qazi is his name in
the mcu he's funded in the comics by
kingpin as well then we have echo and
her origin has kingpin all over it she
works for king ben kingpin raises her
kingpin kills her dad yeah it's pretty
weird so
there's a lot a lot of connections to
kingpin here and i'm not saying he's
gonna show up in the hawkeye series but
he could show up at the end and he may
even show up in the echo series which is
heavily heavily ruined right now along
with matt murdock aka daredevil so we're
gonna break this whole thing down and i
will talk about how i do think kingpin
is behind all of this in several points
in this video and again of course it
could be eleanor bishop being the main
villain of this series but then kingpin
is secretly behind all of it that could
be revealed later on but we're gonna
break it all down and don't forget about
my spider-man collectible giveaway to
enter you just have to subscribe to my
channel and cosmic culture and leave
some comments on some recent videos to
enter the giveaway ends at the end of
this month so let's get into it now the
first episode of hawkeye starts off in
2012 and right away when we see 2012 and
know that we're in new york we
automatically think of the very first
avengers film and the battle of new york
against loki and to chittari and of
course this scene goes on to show that
but we start by going to kate bishop's
room where they show us medals and
trophies that she's won for archery for
fencing there's a picture of her and her
father rock climbing and this is meant
to show how athletic and skilled and
gifted at certain things kate bishop is
especially at such a very very young age
now kate gets up on her dresser to
listen to her parents argue and what
they're arguing about kate's father's
name is derek bishop and her mother is
eleanor bishop and they actually kind of
twist this story a lot from what
actually happens in the comics now in
the comics derek is very wealthy along
with the entire bishop family but here
it looks like they are struggling as
eleanor says they're going to have to
sell the penthouse kate overhears and
some books fall down so the parents know
she's listening in which the dad enters
and says everything's going to be okay
and what this really is setting up right
here is something that kate can cling on
to in the future because as we know her
father will go on to die but we see that
she has a very strong relationship with
her father here he tells her to go have
lunch with her mother and that he'll be
down in his study kate has lunch with
her mother and then she tells her to go
get some checkers while she goes
downstairs real quick and this is
interesting and i'll circle back to this
but while kate gets the checkers that's
where everything starts to happen we get
the battle of new york from the first
avengers film and from here we get some
really awesome scenes scenes from the
avengers film that we saw before but
this time we're getting them from a
different angle now part of the bishop's
penthouse gets destroyed enough for kate
to look out the window and see hawkeye
andy actually saves her life firing an
arrow at some chatari who were about to
kill her she sees hawkeye on top of the
building and we see the classic hawkeye
jumping off the roof while shooting an
arrow that has a rope attached to it
move and these events make hawkeye
kate's favorite avenger and a role model
for her and this is kind of similar to
the comics in the comics kate bishop
witnesses her father beating up somebody
in his study so she decides to kind of
investigate her father and she tracks
him down to a meeting with el matador
her father ends up leaving but el
matador catches her and takes her
hostage but she is saved by hawkeye
hawkeye and the rest of the avengers
show up and she becomes infatuated with
all of them but specifically hawkeye
because he is a normal human with no
powers and this is pretty much the same
scenario here hawkeye saves kate whether
he knows it or not and from here on out
hawkeye is going to be her favorite
avenger and she's going to aim to be
like hawkeye now here her father ends up
dying and her mother ends up living and
this is kind of reverse of what happens
in the comics however i don't know if he
is actually dead the reason being is
because in the comics her mother is
believed to have died she's believed to
have died on a trip to boulder colorado
however it is later on revealed that she
is indeed alive and she's actually kind
of a villain it's revealed that she's
actually directing the activities of
kate's nemesis madame mask so i'm
thinking that her father could actually
be alive they might have just switched
the stories here perhaps her father
returns as somewhat of a villain
especially since they kind of set that
up in the beginning with the parents
arguing however based on everything that
we've seen so far it is also very
possible that her mother eleanor really
is a villain at the funeral kate worries
about the villains coming back and kate
says i need to protect us and the mother
says i'll protect you and do whatever
you need in which kate replies i need a
bow and arrow because she wants to be
like hawkeye now from here in the intro
we actually get some insanely cool art
and illustrations that show us kate
bishop growing up and these images and
illustrations are based off of the matte
fraction hawkeye run now the hawkeye
show itself is based off of the matte
fraction hawkeye run however based off
of the first two episodes it's not
really following the same story the
matte fraction run is pretty raw and in
the matte fraction run hawkeye is
divorced he's kind of a drunk he sits
around in his apartment and his
sweatpants all the time drinks coffee
right out of the pot and the whole thing
is actually kind of a grounded run of
what it's like to really be a superhero
it's not all fame and glory but they
actually have to deal with real stuff
hawkeye kind of sleeps around a little
bit but the banter between him and kate
bishop is pretty awesome they do fight a
lot but they get along at the same time
and it really seems like that's mostly
what we're going to be dealing with here
from the matt fraction run because we
clearly do not have the same hot guy
here he's still married he's got kids it
seems like the relationship is great
however matt fraction's run does deal
with the repercussions of battle and i
will say that we can see that here
especially when it comes to natasha he's
clearly still in a lot of pain mourning
her death which obviously is
understandable now the illustrations
show kate bishop growing up they show
her learning how to shoot a bow and
arrow and when they show the target we
can actually see the avengers tower in
the background they show her getting
better and better as she grows up
winning trophies in martial arts archery
and fencing she even does gymnastics as
well seemingly in front of a lot of
people they show her going from getting
beat up and losing these competitions to
winning and essentially now being a
master at archery and pretty much
everything else that she did we cut to
present time and we see her skills in
live action thanks to a bet to try and
get a huge bell to ring on top of a bell
tower she successfully shoots an arrow
with a tennis ball at the bell's rope
which causes it to ring but
unfortunately causes it to completely
collapse on the building that it sits on
top of but while she's doing this she
gets a call from one of her buddies
greer now in the comics there is a greer
grant who is tigra i doubt her friend
will go on to become tigra but this
could be a little easter egg she also
comments about her outfit in which kate
replies well sometimes you gotta dress
the part but what's really cool about
this is that the outfit she's wearing is
her comic accurate costume and of course
she chose to wear purple because hawkeye
himself wears purple we then cut to new
york and we can see all of the holiday
festivities have begun it's a few days
before christmas and clint has his three
kids they're all taking kind of a dad
vacation with him and they are seeing
rogers the musical a musical that
doesn't really sit too well with clint
and his family in fact clint turns his
hearing aid off so he doesn't really
have to hear it but while having his
hearing aid off and seeing the person
playing natasha he kind of starts to get
a little bit emotional because that was
his best friend his partner and she died
in avengers end game of course but his
daughter kind of snaps him out of it he
turns his hearing back on and he says
you know who wasn't there ant-man which
is true and very interesting that they
put him in this play considering the
fact that he had nothing to do with the
battle of new york there are a few good
lines in it though like we'll conquer
the chitauri and get shwarma when we're
done which is said by the person playing
iron man and this lets us know that the
world in the mcu knows that the avengers
got swarma after the battle of new york
now hawkeye steps away and goes to use
the bathroom and when he gets to the
urinal he sees somebody has wrote thanos
was right on top of it now we started to
see some of this in the falcon and the
winter soldier with the flag smashers
seeing that some people actually
preferred that five year period where
half of the universe was snapped and
seeing as how it's written here i'm
going to assume that we're going to see
more of this in the mcu with more disney
plus shows and movies then someone comes
up to the urinal right next to him
asking to take a selfie and of course
clint says it's not the right time only
to go wash his hands and find the person
standing right behind him now this does
kind of show what it's like to be a
superhero outside of all of the fame and
the glory of the big battles it's not
necessarily ideal all of the time which
is what part of the matte fraction run
tried to do show all the other parts
outside of the big battles that
everybody sees this is further shown
when hawkeye leaves the theater and his
daughter comes out after him and says
that basically it's a lot harder on him
because everybody misses natasha but she
was his best friend we then cut to kate
getting back home from school she goes
to visit her mother upon her mother's
request in which when she gets there her
mother is pretty pissed off about the
bell tower as punishment her mom cancels
all of her credit cards something that
will come into play later kate seems
genuinely sorry but does present her
mother with a medal that she recently
won for martial arts but here we're
actually introduced to a very important
character jacques du kane at least
that's his name in the marvel comics in
the hawkeye show they just call him jack
jack aka jacques ducane in marvel comics
is the villain slash hero swordsman and
his story is actually very interesting
and very connected to hawkeye swordsman
is exactly what his name says he is a
swordsman an expert olympic swordsman
trained with all types of blades and all
types of different weapons in general in
the comics he goes on to fight in some
rebellions but eventually gets a job
with the carson carnival of traveling
wonders now this is very important
because you know who else gets a job at
the same carnival clint barton they meet
working at the carnival and then
swordsmen becomes barton's mentor
teaching him all about swords and how to
use them now eventually clint finds out
that jack was actually stealing from the
carnival in order to pay off some
gambling debts and he rats him out for
it but jack escapes only two years later
run into clint again eventually
swordsman would actually become an
avenger even though hawkeye really
fought against that the two of them
would have grudges towards each other
for a pretty long time but eventually
they put that aside and were able to get
along now i'm not sure if this is going
to be the same story in the hawkeye
series considering the fact that jeremy
renner is actually older than tony
dalton who plays jack but surely they'll
have some type of a connection with each
other maybe they worked together in the
past maybe the carnival was still a
thing in the mcu and instead of jack
being a mentor he was more of a friend
who might have very well betrayed clint
now in the comics again he's more of
like an anti-hero he's bad but he's also
good he's definitely doing some shifty
shady stuff in the hawkeye series but
we'll have to wait and see on him we
then go to a restaurant where clint is
having food with his family also if you
didn't know hawkeye's daughter is played
by ava russo the daughter of joe russo
as in the russo brothers who directed
avengers in game and infinity war
captain america civil war and captain
america winter soldier during the scene
hawkeye gets a call from his wife laura
she is in fact alive and well we just
find out that the whole point of the
trip that hawkeye and his family are
taking is for hawkeye to spend some time
with the kids there's six days left till
christmas and they're trying to have a
lot of fun in the meantime however
hawkeye's trip is about to get cut short
by the one and only kate bishop we cut
to the charity event that kate's mother
eleanor wanted kate to attend and
instead of kate wearing the red dress
that her mother laid out for her on her
bed she is wearing an all-black tuxedo
instead which coincidentally all of the
waiters and waitresses and staff event
workers are wearing as well this will
obviously come to help her in future
events here we're introduced to armand
de king the father of jack de kane in
the comics now armin spills the beans to
kate that his mother is going to be
marrying jack he also revealed that he
tried to convince jack not to marry
eleanor and he says that jack thinks he
won the lottery but he is not so sure
because of eleanor this starts our
suspicion on who eleanor might actually
be and what she's doing again in the
comics she is actually bad and kind of
manages madam mask but some people like
greg over at the real rejects do think
that she could actually be retconned to
be madame mask in this series which is
extremely possible we haven't seen much
yet but it definitely seems like she is
up to something now of course kate has
to go confront her mother and jack about
their engagement that they didn't tell
her about she confronts them in which
eleanor asked jack to give them a minute
in which he says it's time for my other
engagement now this leads me to believe
that perhaps eleanor is in on this whole
underground auction thing that jack is
about to partake in again eleanor is
seeming really sus right now now of
course eleanor is asking kate to be
happy for her and kate says of course
there's a part of me that can be but she
has to step out for some fresh air kate
goes outside and this is the first time
that we meet lucky the pizza dog the
one-eyed dog who loves to eat pizza he
plays a super awesome role in the comics
and we'll break this down a little bit
later when he comes more into the scene
kate soon discovers her mother talking
with armand well more like arguing in
which we hear arman say i've got
powerful friends too this leads me to
believe that perhaps eleanor was
actually threatening armand which is a
little ironic because he is about to die
and that might not be too much of a
coincidence we'll see on that but again
eleanor is looking pretty sus right now
now kate follows armand down to a secret
auction a black market option where we
also see jack where his father tells him
that he's really done with eleanor and
things are about to get ugly again
implying she's doing some pretty shady
stuff the auction begins and the
auctioneer reminds everybody that all of
these items that are being auctioned are
for home use only and that if anybody
asked they did not get them from this
auction because technically it doesn't
exist because it's underground it's
black market they're not supposed to
have any of these items but here we see
that ronin who is the mantle that
hawkeye took on during avengers end game
where he went and killed a bunch of
underground mafias ronan's sword and his
suit are for sale here in the auction
now of course jack being a swordsman
wants to buy the sword but his father
tells us that he doesn't have the money
but jack kind of makes the joke that
he's going to inherit it one day because
his father's rich with armon being the
father and he'll inherit it one day now
ironically armand is about to die now
this scene is really cool because this
is something that is kind of taken from
matt fraction's run in the comics
there's a huge auction in madrapore the
same match report that we saw in the
falcon and the winter soldier kind of
the crime city of the world but this
auction is for a videotape of clint
barton committing a political
assassination sanctioned by shield
therefore sanctioned by the us
government now one of the participants
of this auction is kingpin wilson fisk
and here's where i actually think we
could be getting into who the true
villain could actually be in the comics
wilson fisk is a prominent participant
in this auction and he even later on
goes on to fund the tracksuit mafia and
casimira's kazimierzkuck he funds them
to kill clint barton for being such an
annoyance to his criminal activities so
check this out the people that caused
this explosion and are looking for the
watch they are the tracksuit mafia and
who is the leader of the tracksuit mafia
in this shot kazi which we can assume is
short for kazimierz so this begs the
question is kingpin actually behind the
tracksuit mafia and qazi in the hawkeye
series could kingpin be the actual
villain of the show or could it possibly
be kate's mother eleanor as madame mask
we'll have to wait and see on that one
but i'm hoping it is kingpin so the
tracksuit mafia causes the explosion and
they come into the picture and one of
them coincidentally or maybe not so
coincidentally is wearing a purple ski
mask looking a lot like baron zemo we'll
have to see if there's any connection
down the road to this but the explosion
allows two things one it allows jack to
take the ronin sword and two it allows
kate to take the ronin suit now we hear
the masked people say they have 90
seconds to find the watch everything
else is secondary to that and this is
where kate decides that clearly the
smartest thing to do is to put on the
ronin suit and attack all the bad guys
now she does end up helping all of the
participants get free and this is where
we get a really good glimpse of her
martial arts skills now she manages to
beat the tracksuit mafia which is
impressive considering the fact that
they all had guns even if some luck was
involved meanwhile the watch that the
trexus mafia is looking for was actually
found and we learn a tiny bit about it
there's a tag on it that says 268 lot
number avengers compound so what is this
watch it could perhaps be tony stark's
watching could be some type of stark
tech it could have belonged to ronin as
well or captain america or another hero
or could be some type of weapon that
we're not sure about yet but we'll have
to wait and see now luckily for kate
bishop lucky the pizza dog actually
attacks the guy looking at the watch
then kate comes and knocks him out with
a kick lucky runs kate runs after him
and the tracksuit mafia comes and kazi
does the one thing that every masked
villain should never do out in public he
takes off his mask like a real smart
person but he does us a favor because it
is revealed to be the actor fra free who
is confirmed to play qazi and he even is
wearing a coat that's kind of similar to
zemo's perhaps he's taken inspiration
from him but the cops come and the
tracksuit mafia has to leave now
everything was caught on camera and this
is where things get pretty complicated
for hawkeye hawkeye of course was ronin
and now he sees somebody wearing the
ronin suit on tv this is a really big
problem for twofold one clint knows that
whoever is wearing that suit is going to
be hunted down by some gangs that he
messed up while he was ronin and two
obviously he wants to put that part of
him behind and he can't do that if
somebody's out there pretending to be
ronan which he thinks now in the mcu in
the hawkeye show kate is the one who
saves lucky the one-eyed dog she takes
him back to her apartment and he's
hungry so she gives them the only thing
that she really has pizza and lucky the
pizza dog is born in the mcu but this is
not how it happened in the comics in the
comics lucky's original name was arrow
and he originally belonged to ivan
baniones of the tracksuit mafia however
clint showed him some kindness and arrow
repaid the favor by attacking the
tracksuit mafia unfortunately this
caused the tracksuit mafia to beat him
almost to death and throw him into
traffic clint rushed him to a veterinary
hospital where they saved him but
unfortunately he lost one of his eyes
from there on out hawkeye took ownership
of the dog and later on kate bishop now
she ends up tracking armand and we later
on find out in episode two that the
reason that she's able to do this is
because her mom owns a security company
so she's got some pretty sick software
on her phone it leads her to armin's
place where she finds out that he's been
murdered she bails but then the
tracksuit mafia is waiting for her she
tries to take them on but unfortunately
there are too many of them but luckily a
hooded figure comes to save the day and
of course that is hawkeye hawkeye grabs
her takes her to an alleyway unmasks her
and realizes that she's just a young
girl and is pretty upset about that
because now she's in a lot of trouble
and hawkeye knows that he can't just
leave her with the traction mafia and
the suit because everyone who was after
ronin is going to be after her and we
end on episode 1. now episode 2 was
right after and there are a few key
details that you need to know it picks
up right where episode 1 left off
hawkeye and kate in the alley hawkeye
asks who she is she says she's kate
bishop and hawkeye immediately realizes
that he's gonna have to make sure she's
okay before he leaves especially if
she's still wearing the ronin suit
because people are after ronin we go to
herman's hearty slice which kate bishop
lives above and no doubt this is where
lucky the pizza dog is going to get all
of his pizza from they go in the
building and hawkeye turns around and
puts his head on the glass because he
knows that he's about to get into a lot
having to take care of this girl we get
to her apartment and we can see a lot of
things that kate has up for training we
can see a target with a bunch of arrows
in it a punchy bag in the back and this
hawkeye kind of looks through her stuff
we can see all the trophies that she's
won for archery and hawkeye does notice
this he asked where she got the suit and
of course she says the truth a black
market auction then he asked what she
did because he is wondering how much
trouble she is actually in and
coincidentally himself since he's kind
of gonna have to watch out for her now
although this isn't particularly his
fault that she grabbed the suit and put
it on and kind of went against the
tracksuit mafia it kind of is his fault
that he became running in the first
place but i think we all understand why
and after all he only killed bad guys
not good guys but anyways now in the
scene hawkeye officially confirms that
these bad guys are the tracksuit mafia
and kate asked do you think they're the
people who killed my mother's fiance's
uncle so armand is actually his uncle in
this not jack's father here hawkeye
explains what i've pretty much explained
already a lot of people are looking for
the person who wore that suit ronan that
person made a lot of enemies and hawkeye
wanted to make sure that nobody saw who
kate bishop was nobody saw her face
nobody knows who she was but
unfortunately after the auction kate
dropped off lucky at her apartment and
they figured out that it was her the
tracksuit mafia shows up throw molotov
cocktails at the apartment where hawkeye
busts the window grabs one in midair and
throws it back then another one is about
to throw it but kate bishop snipes it
out of his hand with a bow and arrow her
taking this opportunity to prove to
hawkeye that she is actually a very good
archer hawkeye kate and lucky end up
escaping through the fire exit and cool
little note it shows the tracksuit mafia
after and one of them is deaf or at
least very hard of hearing and this is
kind of a big thing of the show hawkeye
has his hard of hearing as well and echo
is going to be introduced who of course
is deaf also echo is another tie-in and
hint that kingpin really could be the
main villain of this because at first
she works for kingpin but in these next
scenes is where we really start to see
the banter and the relationship between
kate and hawkeye she looks up to him and
is excited to go on this grand adventure
with him she asks if they're going to
the avengers tower if they're getting
some avengers supplies but he takes her
to a pharmacy to get neosporin she says
it's a letdown and was hoping to go to
the avengers tower and he explains that
tony sold that a few years ago hawkeye
explains the plan that he needs to stash
her and take care of everything and she
compares herself to a bag of money which
shakai says no a bag of money is useful
to me this is just the beginning of the
banter in the relationship between
hawkeye and kate kate says she knows a
place to go about 10 blocks away they go
to an apartment building and she looks
up on all the names and she sees a name
that says moira brandon and this is a
really cool easter egg lara brandon in
the comics was an actress raised in
chicago who moved to california to
become an actress she ended up making a
lot of films and becoming a movie star
but eventually her career dried up and
she retired and she retired to an estate
that eventually the west coast avengers
would purchase and turn into their new
avengers compound so this is coming
right after clint says that tony sold
the old avengers compound now they have
one in upstate but perhaps this is the
beginning of a new avengers compound
here at least for the series myra would
end up saving clint and mockingbird but
she would die but right before she died
clint made her an honorary avenger now
of course the mcu loves to switch things
up and in this case they are saying that
moira is kate's aunt she's away for the
winter in florida so hawkeye stashes
kate there and he goes to retrieve the
ronin suit however when he gets to her
apartment the new york fire department
is there but he quickly gets a disguise
goes in and realizes the suit is gone he
realizes that one of the firemen must
have taken it then he sees a sticker on
one of the fire trucks that says nyc
larpers and that's enough evidence for
him he goes back to kate's apartment and
we see more of their banter but this
time we see that it's kind of a
love-hate relationship she says things
like when did your heart shrink and he
says when a little girl in a costume
stole my christmas but then he realizes
that she didn't clean her wounds
properly so he helps because he actually
does care despite being so annoyed
hawkeye has a little moment with lucky
the pizza dog which i thoroughly enjoyed
even though it was quick and then he
goes back to his family so we can
actually send them home early
unfortunately after discovering that an
nyc larper another young man has the
ronin costume and is publicly saying
that he has it he realizes that he still
has much more work to do so in order to
keep the kids out of harm's way he sends
them home to their mother we also see a
scene where his youngest son is trying
to speak with him via sign language and
we can actually see that hawkeye does
know a little bit of sign language at
least now in the comics hawkeye was kind
of stubborn and kind of refused to learn
sign language at first but it doesn't
look like he's so stubborn here we
return to myra's apartment where we can
actually see posters on the wall of
movies that she's been in including
creature of the dark galaxy here it's
decided that kate will go to work
because she works for her mother who
owns a security company so it's a safe
place then clint will go and retrieve
the suit and everything should be done
with but on their way there they have an
interesting conversation one we figure
out why in the mcu clint is hard of
hearing now and it makes just a ton of
sense he's been through a lot of
explosions so after all those blasts and
explosions his ears have taken a beating
and it seems like he can hear a lot
better out of the left ear than his
right ear now in the scene a child says
mommy look a superhero both kate and
clint turn because they think the child
is talking about him hawkeye but they
run right past hawkeye to go see some of
the actors on the streets of new york
who are acting as the avengers and one
who kate actually mistakes for hawkeye
which is actually katniss everdeen from
the hunger games and from here this is
where kate kind of gets a little deep
she says that his problem is branding he
jokingly replies no it's you now this
whole pitch by kate is really saying
that hawkeye's low-key and not really
out there he doesn't wear his heart on
the sleeve he's kind of dark and
mysterious and that's kind of hard to
sell nowadays because people like to
relate with these heroes but hawkeye
says a couple of times that he's not
trying to sell anything but kate makes
it clear that whether he is trying to or
not he is selling something and he
doesn't know what it is but kate tells
him it's inspiration inspiration as a
superhero but really what it seems like
she's trying to do here is kind of
validate hawkeye as this person that she
looks up to they always say don't meet
your heroes because they'll disappoint
you and it seems like this is kind of
what is happening right here she's met
hawkeye and she thought it was going to
be a completely different experience
because this is the person that saved
her life in 2012 and this is a person
that she aspired to be like she aspired
to be a hero like hawkeye that's why she
trained in archery and martial arts and
swordsmanship so she's just trying to
validate hawkeye in this scene now
hawkeye gets her number just in case
there's an emergency but he pretty much
tells her hopefully everything goes to
plan and he'll never see her again now
from here things get kind of weird but
they also get kind of funny kate goes
into her mom's office where jack is
actually there currently kate does some
interrogating with jack about his uncle
who died armond and the inheritance that
jack would now get and jack talks about
how he bought a book about being a
stepdad which only made things worse
however kate did agree to have dinner
with the two of them that night as long
as she could bring up the topic
meanwhile hawkeye finds himself in a
ridiculous predicament he finds himself
at the nyc larpers and larp is live
action role playing so the people who do
that are called larpers he sees the
person who has the ronin suit but
unfortunately the staff doesn't let him
buy which i find a little bit ridiculous
because i feel like clint would just
walk by but he does at one point and say
he does not want to cause a scene out of
respect for the event and i definitely
respect him for that so in order to get
close to this person he has to larp live
action roleplay he puts on the costume
the armor grabs the sword goes up to the
guy and as it turns out the guy is
actually a pretty cool guy he recognizes
hawkeye and he says that he's a hero in
real life and that he'll give him the
suit if he just lets him defeat him in
battle during the larp because that's
the closest he's ever gonna get to being
a superhero which i totally get now
hawkeye's a good guy and they fight and
the other guy wins but it's obviously
because hawkeye did not drink that
potion like he was supposed to but he
puts on a show and grylls is now a hero
and hawkeye admits that he kinda did
have a little bit of fun there and now
hawkeye finally has the suit now here
hawkeye stashes the suit in a locker
while he's talking to his wife laura and
he says concerning the tracksuit mafia
he's not sure how high up this goes and
again this is getting me thinking that
kingpin could be at the very very top
and takai has a plan for this he plans
to get himself caught that way he can
get taken to the boss of the tracksuit
mafia and he even ends this conversation
with his wife and says time to go get
caught now we return to kate having
dinner with her mother eleanor and her
fiance jack and she just tries to figure
out more about jack who he is and she
knows that he likes swords and they talk
about fencing as it turns out they both
fence so what do they do of course
naturally they have to fence each other
now jack lets her win obviously he's
trying to be a good stepfather future
stepfather but that only makes kate mad
so he continuously lets her win and when
his guard is down and his helmet is off
she goes to hit him but he parries it
and he deflects her proving that he was
actually downplaying his abilities like
he says and he did lie about letting her
win over and over again she obviously
was there during the underground auction
and knows that he has something to hide
and is trying to get it out of him but
i'm willing to bet that her mother is
probably in on it as well so when it
finally does come to light it's going to
be a complete shock to kate and this is
hinted at a little bit more in the
conversation that her mother has with
her her mother tells her no more
snooping because she's going to get hurt
and it's not just going to be scrapes on
her knees she most likely knows this due
to the fact that she's kind of behind
some of the stuff that is going down at
least they're really making her seem
like that to me it seems like jack is
kind of too upfront to be the villain
they're kind of making it seem like he
is the villain which leads me to believe
that he's not perhaps he's just kind of
an innocent arrogant rich guy and maybe
his uncle was right maybe eleanor is
actually the problem not good enough
because maybe she's a little bit evil
and maybe she's the one who actually
killed armand because to me where he
offers her a butterscotch where it's
armin's butterscotch that she found in
armin's apartment that literally has his
name on the wrapper it just seems a
little too obvious to me but we'll see
about it meanwhile hawkeye is getting
himself captured even as a bow and arrow
to really distinguish that he is hawkeye
the tracksuit mafia does find him they
take him and they say she
wants him alive which is a great
indicator of who was about to be
introduced and everything kind of goes
according to hawkeye's plan he gets
himself caught breaks out of whatever
constraints he was in pretty easily and
simply asked to speak to the tracksuit
mafia's boss and this scene makes it
very clear and apparent how dumb these
guys actually are he denies knowing kate
bishop and is trying to explain that
she's not the person they're looking for
but unfortunately she crashes through
the ceiling and kind of ruins hot guys
plans at least temporarily now they get
duct taped up again together and we
start to hear music coming from a
distant room where some of the tracksuit
mafia members say you're in trouble now
because the real boss is coming out into
the room there's music playing from a
bunch of speakers in which we see a hand
over one of the speakers this is because
the character that is introduced right
here echo is deaf she can't hear but she
can feel and that's where the episode
ends with the big reveal that echo is in
charge of the tracksuit mafia at least
at this level it could definitely go
higher than her and i actually do think
it does go higher than her i think it
could go up to kingpin because in the
comics she actually works for kingpin
and in a really really weird way kingpin
is the one who kills her father her
father asks kingpin as his dying wish to
raise his daughter and what she does now
later on she would fall in love with
matt murdock she would get assigned to
kill daredevil and realize that matt
murdock is daredevil and matt would
explain everything to her including how
kingpin is a terrible guy so a lot of
things in these first two episodes
actually point to kingpin being behind
everything between the auction the
tracksuit mafia ekko and kazi who we did
see there at the end a lot of things
point to kingpin but let me know what
you think in the comments down below do
you think that kingpin could be in
charge of this all you think he could
get introduced in this series we know
that he's probably gonna be in the echo
series but could he be in this series
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and let me know what
you think about hawkeye episodes one and
two don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any mcu news
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof